[Music]
so in general what you want to do is
stand a little bit tall so like the top
of your head is floating towards the sky
and your pelvic floor is dropping
towards the ground we're just going to
do a little bit of this you're not
scooping your butt you're simply letting
your tailbone go a little heavy the top
your head grow long so your spine grows
a little bit long so it's a bit of a
feeling of being just gently stretched
tall you don't need to scoop it's just
tightening the pelvic floor so it's like
you're pushing up a little bit on a
button in between your anus and your
genitals yep and that actually tightens
up all the muscles that wrap around your
spine and support your core
let your chest open a little bit you
know it's sort of just kind of like a
feeling good heart kind of way then your
shoulders gently rolled together in the
back so your shoulder blades are gently
rolling together and down your back it's
all very gentle never crunch never
tighten never pull it's more like a
relaxed inflation of of your body so
this is always going to be kind of a bit
of a default thing to come back through
as you're playing play growing tall your
heart opening and your shoulder blades
gently falling down your back and your
shoulders staying in place so we'll keep
coming back to that while within that
there's gonna be a lot of turning where
any given turn we might be starting
forward this way and we're going to turn
to this way so we're turning from side
to side so one thing I want you to do
from the beginning is to begin to
develop how you do that with your whole
body and your feet such a way that your
posture can stay strong and straight and
you're not putting any pressure on your
knees or any specific point in your body
so let's start with this if just trading
side to side Mariah
my brilliant camera woman you got under
my feet
okay good nom I feel like this there we
go
so what you'll see that I'm doing as I
turn to the side I'm pivoting both my
feet a little bit and lifting my back
heel and and that lets me turn or if I
was talking on the knee in general you
want your knees over your toes is the
general theory so you come back up a
little bit so as I go side to side
I could let that back heel push away and
what I'm doing up here is my whole body
my hips my waist everything is involved
I'm keeping this sort of tallness I'm
keeping my pelvic floor a little bit
activated then I'm able to turn from
side to side and see how I'm staying in
place
I'm not going like this no that's bad I
want to be able to stay in place so if
I'm turning like this I've got a
tallness I've got that sort of core a
little bit engaged I've got it's like
I'm a ninja with a book on my head as
David Yates would say who's your book on
the head and I can turn in side to side
so this is one of the defaults there's
so many things for doing it's all going
to be learning you know turning the
weaves all kinds of returns maybe
turning in opposites boom boom and it's
always gonna be that simple pivot and
you want to be able to do that without
putting any pressure on your knee
so I recommend when you're first warming
up always throw deep employ just start
to do a little bit of dancing as you're
warming up and have it turning side to
side or you're learning turn in a
comfortable way and then you're going to
stack ply on top of that as you go and
make sense
[Music]